musician Ben kweller Reveals His Son
Dorian has died the 16 year old was
reportedly killed in a car accident on
Monday
[Applause]
and shared the tragic news to Instagram
calling his late son a true legend and
gentle soul Ben and his wife Liz are
also parents to son Judah the family is
in complete shock and don't know what
the future holds condolences poured in
from the music Community Michelle Branch
told them I'm so sorry heartbreaking
model Lily Aldridge who's married to
Kings of Leon singer Caleb followwell
sent love and prayers Taylor Hansen said
he feels Beyond heartbreak and added
love you quellers
in 2011 Ben shared this moment Dorian
playing drums with Dad when he was just
two
[Music]
years later Dorian started his own music
Journey under his middle name Zev Ben
wrote in his caption my last text with
him was about the merch she wanted to
make my baby boy was at the starting
line with so much life ahead of him I
got invited to play South by Southwest
and then hopefully I'll be dropping some
new music around then yeah it's gonna be
a great time Ben laments only a few of
his recordings were released but he was
on a path and excited about his journey
[Music]
foreign